that's some american ninja warrior grip
you got there
i'm surprised she hasn't fallen yet oh
there she is
[Music]
baby those credits
i love a post-credits indeed yeah there
he is oh my god what the heck god
a cosplayer with too much time on their
hands not this one i never trusted this
man
yeah bring her in
ooh
shifty eye from cleary larry's not
telling us something welcome back to new
rock stars miss marvel episode 1 leaves
us blinded by the light but not the odc
agent cleary in the post-credits scene
after interrogating peter parker and his
friends and spider-man no way home why
is the dodc back in this series and why
does asian clery hide a look of
recognition the first time you see
kamala khan use her powers what what is
going on
we're working on our on our big screamy
part at the beginning i think what is
going on is pretty good that was a that
was a pitch by mr brandon barry i think
it's a part oh what is going on i dig i
said it was going on
this is inside marvel it's new rockstars
after show for miss marvel on disney
plus i'm eric boss my easter egg
breakdown of this episode and there were
like 3000 of them it's gonna be coming
later today right now i'm reacting to
this first episode with mt mt what do
you think of this series so far bro like
zero cap like i am enjoying the hell out
of this series i'm a big fan of scott
pilgrim like just the whole aesthetic of
scott pilgrim and like obviously into
the spider verse who doesn't love it and
we got both the best of both the smashed
into one and this having this super
charismatic nerdy character super
enthusiastic about marvel heroes like we
are it's just like really this is really
cool to see this new like this new
different looking marvel mcu hero on the
screen um and presented in like a super
fun way that we've never seen before
like the cinematography of the show is
super beautiful and it's so clever yeah
the the shot composition is all really
cool the use of light in the show is
beautiful acting is just so fun like
this is getting to know this family
getting to know this girl like i love
her dad so much
i love her mom
the way she defends her daughter to
others like to the driving instructor
but then like when they get in the car
she starts criticizing like there's such
a truth to that the only difference is
like my parents would throw me under the
bus all the time like if i brushed into
the family they would say well this is
not becoming of the ross family we will
talk to you home and then once i got in
the car they'd be like it's fine it was
kind of a reversal
with my experience but like i totally
like i mentioned this to you when we
were heading into this series that just
based off of the trailer it seemed like
we all either were ourselves or had a
friend or had a crush on uh someone like
kamala khan growing up or me
i definitely had friends like molokai i
had a crush as a kid on on other komala
cons and my grades uh when i was in high
school like this was high school for me
this pressure of like needing to have
your life all figured out when you're 16
years old um
of like figuring yourself out of like
your family is trying to relate with you
but they just can't and then feeling
really guilty when you yell at your
family right
when having an older sibling who gets
married when you're in high school and
having to drop everything to do wedding
planning that's something that i had
when i was in sophomore year of high
school i uh two of my older sisters got
married in the same year and that was my
entire life was like as a teenager
figuring out their wedding so like
there's so many ways that like i was
able to connect with this and it was
just weird i mean not to mention the
fact that it opens with a youtube video
like if you're in the world of marvel
youtube how could you not connect with
the show it felt like weirdly like
right watching us i was like
this is meta
yeah i was i was smiling ear to ear
watching this episode like it was so
funny how can you not it's just so much
fun bro like i don't know i just had a
lot of fun i can't wait for the next
episode so let's quickly recap what we
saw this first episode introduces us to
a 16 year old kamala khan a pakistani
american girl living in jersey city huge
fan of the avengers especially captain
marvel she makes animated home videos
that she uploads to her youtube channel
sloth baby productions recounting the
events of avengers end game of course
highlighting carol danvers i love that
she's so active on youtube and we see
all of our youtube video thumbnails
where it's like those took me rock stars
thumbnails that's we've made those
videos before 100
and and that was one thing that uh i was
very flattered to learn uh from the miss
marvel panel that
several of the cast and crew including
him on uh watch his new rock stars and
his fans of our videos those are just so
sweet well they tweeted that i freaked
out because like if we're helping miss
marvel
like get hype about marvel like i feel
like our my life is complete like good
god yeah so cool it was it was so so
satisfying to hear that and it was like
uh super validating for one uh not that
we need uh you know so much validation
but no inject that validation in my
veins
and i asked like if there was a new rock
stars in the marvel cinematic universe
and i i said like you have our
permission to make a sims buchanan and
kevin feige laughed he heard the
question you know he's thinking it now
uh and then uh iman you know couldn't
couldn't decide what is canon or not but
she was like you know i feel like at
least a variant of new rock stars is
exists in the end oh my god i hope so
kevin you have my permission to put me
please put me in the mcu i would cry i
would cry
i mean some are saying that we did uh
start to take credit for this when a
good morning america showed up in the
mcu because i've done a couple spots on
good morning america this past year so
like by extension it's true mma is in
the mcu i've been on gma
you are
an mcu character i mean if you think
about it there are uh several ways all
of us uh can be mcu canon just by what
like historical events and what you know
you can do that six degrees of
separation uh in all kinds of ways but
one confirmation we got in this opening
scene is that we learned that kamala
khan learned all this in-game history
from scott lang's podcast big me little
me of this powered life which
little fun joke but actually answered so
many questions as to how the general
public of the mcu knows what happened in
end game and through infinity war and
scott of course wasn't there for the
events on titan and during the battle uh
the battles of wakanda or anything like
that but just by being friends with all
them this this is how they all got that
information out there so we meet her
parents the strict meneva and the more
laid-back youssef and her brother amir
who is getting married soon and uh
kamala fails her driving test and then
we meet her friends bruno and nakia the
popular girl in school zoe and the
guidance counselor mr wilson hilarious
uh it seemed like a nod to g willow
wilson that we actually got a great nod
to all the comic book artists and
writers as the founders of the school
there at the beginning that was really
cool to see kamala and bruno plan to go
to avengers con the first avengers con
and camp lehigh of course caps uh bases
training camp and uh in his movies if
they go back to an end game uh and then
i just love all the animated graffiti as
they're daydreaming about different
cosplay options for the captain marvel
cosplay contest uh that was really fun
to see felt very uh
felt very into the spider verse and
scott pilgrim you know uh just their
whole the whole world here is just so
vibrant and colorful it's like a living
comic book and i dig it so much so
kamala's grandmother her nanny sends her
a box containing a mysterious bangle
that her mother quickly has a mere whisk
away to the attic and then we explore
kamala's pakistani american community
the pressures that kamal is under how
the aunties of this community don't
really like it when the girls of the
family follow their dreams and go off on
their own path and then maniva and yusuf
refuse to let kamala go to avengers con
but bruno hooks her up with these led
gloves for her cosplay calling them
photon
gloves capital p photon in the closed
caption we'll talk about that more in a
bit now our man bruno is crushing hard
uh but poor kamala blinded by that light
doesn't see it but we're
we're there with you bruto we've been
there
and all we got to say at this point
spend a bit more time on your own
cosplay bruno like she'll she'll find
you gotta you gotta work on your own
feathers you know once you have your own
plumage she'll she'll she'll pay
attention but if all you're just
spending all your time on her cosplay i
thought it was really nice i thought it
was nice too i'm just saying like you're
not gonna get anywhere buddy no like i
thought it was really nice that he
dressed up as bruce banner because like
he assumed that she was gonna be the
hulk because of her dad so like he was
like right and i was like yeah he's
dressed up as bruce banner in
preparation and like she just dressed up
as captain marvel he's like oh don't
worry about it bruno is crushing hard
man he's trying that's an excellent
point empty i honestly think uh kamala
should have gone with her dad youssef
yeah bro she broke his heart she broke
his heart we could all hear the david
banner music from the 70s show the 1780s
show in the back of her mind there like
that was heartbreaking and like that
would have been a great trio to go
together you know bruno is good friends
with yusuf designing uh zuzu for him
right that would have been an amazing
combination you have your bruce banner
you have your little hulk every big old
you have the evolution his dad was so
enthusiastic and he was like yeah let's
go and i was like oh my god i wish i had
a dad that's enthusiastic about marvel
stuff are you kidding me i'm like he
doesn't really understand it but like he
wants to support you that's amazing i i
booed kamal at that moment i was like
boo come on come on do better
and you know what i get teenagers
feeling embarrassed by this but the man
put on face paint and that was the day
before it was he was gonna have to take
off that face paint and then put it back
on the next day unless he was gonna
sleep in that face paint when you're
gonna get it like
come on yeah so they sneak away to the
convention and yeah it's filled with uh
fun mcu references uh apparently kevin
feige has uh plans potentially to make a
real avengers con in real life uh
because this looked awesome yes i i want
to go to that yeah that looks all the
different booths looked incredible like
those those were fun they had real life
stuff that hulk smashed there's great
they had uh asgardian ale or mjolnir ale
is what they called it is like
i saw a gamora cosplayer i was like you
know gamora like she was barely here you
have gabor cosplayers that's amazing
there was a drax cosplayer oh yeah but
again i think a lot of this it's coming
from scotland's podcast scotland is just
spilling all the beans and describing
people visually
uh sharing any pictures he has and
putting them in the notes of the podcast
listing i'm sure like yeah that's good i
feel like that makes sense why ant-man
is in the uh the musical because like he
wasn't there but like people just put
him in there because of the podcast
there you go
right
oh absolutely
um yeah ant-man's just inserting himself
into history you know the guy can insert
himself anywhere so why not um
so
during the the captain marvel cosplay
contest is coming up so kamala goes the
bathroom changes into her cosplay but
she forgets her photon gloves
the one
cool thing that bruno spent all that
time on he's a very forgiving guy so she
puts on her grandmother's bangle and
then in this moment gets coated in
cosmic light she falls backwards into a
mysterious realm filled with a shadowy
figure some purple baldies and then upon
taking the stage gets blinded by camera
flashes and blasts from her hand what
everyone on the show right now is just
calling hard light the kind of
crystalline uh
blasts of uh planes or whatever it is
you know it's just crystalline
projections of her own body uh and then
one of these knocks loose a giant
ant-man head that boulders through the
convention and causes a giant
millionaire to swipe zoe and then kamala
saves her by embiggening her hand to
catch her but kamala arrives home and
muniba sculptor but kamala doesn't care
she is thrilled by her new cosmic powers
now in the post-credits scene dodc agent
cleary returns from spider-man no way
home in orders to bring this mass light
caster in but he has this interesting
expression on his face like he knows
something that his other agent agent
steven does not we're going to talk
about what agent cleary's connection is
what damage control is doing in this
show uh why they're after these specific
enhanced individuals who have these
specific kind of powers and whether he
knows who all those purple baldies were
and why kamala khan's powers look the
way they do
because of course
you know at this point if you're
watching this episode they did change
kamala khan's powers in the comics in
the comics she has more of a reed
richards-like ability to embiggen and
stretch her limbs uh in this show it's
taking the form of light hard light is
what they're calling it for now and uh
kevin feige has made a lot of statements
about well this is more in line with the
era of mcu that we're in right now which
could mean a lot of different things it
could mean a connection to carol danvers
and monica rambo as uh kamala khan will
join them in the marvels next year uh it
could refer to as we've speculated last
week something more connected to
spiritual beliefs and the faith of
characters uh i personally hope that's
the direction they go because uh we're
learning a lot about uh mythology and
spiritual beliefs in the mcu i think
that's been a really really cool aspect
of phase four but before we get into all
that we want you to head on over to
newarkstarsmerch.com to catch our newest
latest obsession shirt this is a star
wars theme one empire's most wanted
inspired by the obi-wan kenobi series
when you purchase this latest obsession
shirt you're going to unlock the ability
to get a custom shout out that will
appear on wikileaks that's our obi-wan
kenobi after show but we're going to
have another separate latest obsession
shirt for miss marvel that we're going
to be talking about on this show so keep
an eye out for that we're gonna be uh
jumping on that soon and uh like all of
our latest obsession shirts they're only
available for a limited time be sure to
check them out at new rockstarsmerch.com
grab it today all right mt first episode
of miss marvel what's the first thing
we're talking about we got to talk about
that post-credits scene man because does
agent cleary know where kamala khan's
powers come from because he had that
suspicious look i don't know what what
he knows but he's just like
i want that power for myself and let's
read into it so ariana maya's agent
cleary was one of the more interesting
characters to come out of spider-man no
way home because i've realized that all
of the mcu spider-man movies homecoming
far from home no no way home are sony
productions mostly but they have marvel
studios weighing in and co-producing and
there are always very clear uh
delineated chunks of the movie that uh
are where like there's like a switch has
been flipped and then now marvel has
made it like an mcu joint and suddenly
it's like a marvel it's like an episode
of uh a marvel disney plush show uh and
no way home those moments were very
clearly the first act investigation
montage with the dodc with matt murdock
the references to tony stark and stark
industries the references to iron man 3
all that stuff that was a kevin feige
joint and then when peter goes to the
sanctum sanctorum uh walking like even
the easter eggs are like mcu easter eggs
it seems like they just hand that over
to marvel studios at that point so if we
consider agent cleary being part of the
marvel side of it it makes sense that
asian clery comes back here and in that
movie he told peter an interesting line
that we it was very clearly a clue but
we haven't yet got an answer to it the
line was nick fury has been off planet
for the past year and peter's like
what uh
the line was of course a reference to
the fact that in spider-man far from
home the nick fury that peter was
dealing with was actually fury's scroll
doppelganger taylor spin mendelson's
character and that moment was meant to
set up secret invasion i'm pretty
certain of that because we never got
answers to how cleary who's just a dodc
agent would have any idea what nick
fury's whereabouts were the fact that
he'd be off planet the fact that he's on
a space station with skrulls nick fury
is a secretive guy he wouldn't tell many
people that and i don't think the dodc
would uh be sharing um notes with nick
fury uh because especially now that the
dodc is investigating and prosecuting
stark industries and other avengers
allies in this world uh like happy hogan
didn't know it was uh fury was a
squirrel peter parker didn't know fury
was a scroll so why would the
see
unless
this one guy
has dual loyalties
there was also the matter and this might
just be me matt murdock he was magically
able to get the dodc to drop the charges
against peter now of course matt murdock
a wonderful attorney he's a local
criminal defense attorney he is not a
federal attorney working federal cases
like war crimes and treason murders
committed in the uk
uh i just think we can look past that
because whatever he's a lawyer he's a
marvel lawyer i'm sure he can work a lot
of different cases but i think there is
reason to believe that agent cleary's
prosecution of peter parker and now his
investigation of kamala khan might be a
bit performative
might be a role that he plays as a mole
within the dodc but he's actually loyal
to a different team and for me right now
the likeliest explanation of him knowing
that nick fury was off planet with
scrolls is that cleary himself could be
part of the scroll network either
himself a scroll in disguise or someone
who is working with the squirrels a
human who is working with the scrolls
there's a couple different ways we can
look at it that's just right now there's
a couple indicators pointing in that
direction my god so we come back to this
interesting expression when he sees
kamala's powers on the phone video the
other agent agent stever claims that
we've never seen powers like that before
uh and although cleary says to bring her
in his expression indicates that he
might have seen this kind of power
before and it's really freaking him out
a specific kind of tech a specific kind
of cosmic energy hard light whatever it
is i think he knows that it's
extraterrestrial i think he's seen it
before and the fact that this bengal
came from kamala's grandmother in
pakistan is more important to kamala in
the short term i think because that
tells her more about her family and that
her family has uh has a cooler history
than i think she gives the credit for uh
but there was a subtle line from muniba
after the driver's test where she hated
how much her mother nani kamala's
grandmother was a daydreamer and that
kamala's just like her so now the fact
that that same woman is giving kamala
this bangle i think we're gonna learn a
lot more about nani and how she might
have been an interesting character from
the cosmos maybe an extraterrestrial
refugee maybe an alien super weapon of
some kind a skrull a cree an inhuman
created by the cree
someone kind of like peter quill like
another earth stuck star child someone
who has some extraterrestrial origin but
is just bound to earth and has some
inner power that they didn't realize um
and i think this bangle very clearly
contains some kind of extraterrestrial
technology it could be skrull tech it
could be createc it could be inhuman
tech uh but i think cleary as a squirrel
whatever it is has seen it before and
i'm gonna guess ultimately that it's
some kind of cree tech that was passed
on to inhumans because kamala khan is uh
has pterogenesis that gives her her
powers which is a process by which
inhumans are created and in humans are
human science experiments created by the
cree uh through the stereogenesis
process uh and i think the cree tech is
specifically what scares cleary if he
were a scroll because remember there's
that line from taylor's inspired me
apart from home about the cree sleeper
cells right and that might be what nani
was involved with because the cree and
their imperial staffers to snuff out the
skrull in the shadow war that's
happening on several planets something
that's going to be in the backdrop of
secret invasion uh might have created
these inhumans bioweapons on earth and
nestled them in sleeper cells on earth
just waiting for the right moment to
activate them and this bangle now
igniting maybe declaring could be a
skrull seeing a cree sleeper cell
shifting into attack mode that's just my
theory for clary's reaction but i want
to hear your thoughts what do you think
is going on with clear emt
like that's a really good like
connection with like the whole like
cleary could be a scroll thing because
like it's highly likely because like if
that is the case if that is the case you
got to think about what damage control
is to the mcu because like if you
remember from uh spider-man homecoming
they had all that [ __ ] in their uh
storage facility like that ultron heads
they were like basically storing all
these weapons from all of these avengers
conflicts so like
if clear he's working for the department
of damage control and he's like um
that's another thing that we could add
to our volts
and he's and he could be a scroll maybe
the squirrels are just stacking up on
weapons to prepare for a massive assault
on humanity so like that would be
bananas i would love like i love that
when you said that i was like oh my god
cleary could be a scroll it makes so
much sense um but like i think with
cleary there there's also be a
possibility that he's just working with
um
agent 13 uh sharon carter because we
know that armor wars is coming up soon
in that um sharon carter is a weapons
dealer if damage control has all these
weapons and he's seeing this new extra
terrestrial weapon he's like all right i
want this so i can sell this to sharon
that'd be really like fun for me
because i'm a corrupt cop and uh you
think he's corrupt okay yeah i just
think he's scared i mean before when i
first met him i thought he was team
mysterio because like he was just being
super aggressive with um with mj and and
uh they was like yeah i know my rights
like you can't do this like this i was
like you're not a cop you're being
really not cop-like you're being sketchy
um but like now that we know more about
this character and like he's being
introduced in miss marvel um he i
definitely think that he's a
he's obviously part of the dodc but like
he there's something going on like he
has other loyalties that we don't really
know um and seems to be implied at the
end of this episode for sure i think um
we still don't know a villain for this
series right we don't know who the
ultimate villain is going to be
uh right it's kind of pointed in a
couple different directions if you've
read the comics but
what i would love is just like an mcu
story without a clear villain i kind of
like it if we're just exploring the
world and there's other antagonistic
forces that they're trying to overcome
maybe within their family or within
their community or within themselves um
or within their own history you know um
like i think yeah there's like a couple
different ways you go you don't but i
get it it is a superhero genre you kind
of need like
many believe you need a clear super
villain uh that matches him i don't know
i think we're kind of evolved past that
but
i don't know if uh if cleary and the
dodc is uh enough of a villain that is
specifically tailored for kamala khan i
think they're definitely part of this
world but if they are the ultimate
villain um i don't think that's going to
be uh the the most interesting battle
for her to fight i think obviously
there's a conflict between them right
and i think they are not necessarily on
kamala's side
uh but my thinking is if he is a
squirrel i think the dodc and damage
control are uh representing like a
cleanup crew who's just trying to
prevent this war from breaking out into
the public square so you have militant
groups of cree you have militant groups
of scroll i assume led by varenke which
i think is going to be emilia clarke's
character um they're happy to just start
firing uh through you know skyscrapers
and have another 2012 battle of new york
and damage control is like look if
you're gonna do this it has to be a cold
war and preferably get it off this
planet and then so i think dodc has
squirrels working with them to cover it
up to to keep you know human society
from freaking out because if they find
out that
you know extraterrestrials are in their
midst they're going to lose their minds
and turn against each other so i don't
know if it's all of the dodc but my
theory is that it is it is cleary i
think clearly the fact that he knew that
fury was off planet is not something
that your average dodc agent should know
uh and i don't think fury would just
happily tell him that seriously like
fury moves in silence bro like most
people don't know what fury is doing
right but i think
i i'm just fascinated by him having seen
this tech before i love that you bring
up the fact that uh you know they
cleaned up all the chitari tech and had
all the other stuff in that huge vault
in spider-man uh homecoming um but i
think to me it tells us that uh they've
seen extraterrestrial weaponry used
before
uh and i think they know something about
it uh my hope is that
the word inhuman comes up at some point
yeah
comes up at some point in the show
just to kind of uh stay true to her
powers it doesn't mean it doesn't mean
that like we have to deny this being uh
uh something within her family i think
we want to learn more about her
grandmother uh but i think it'd be
really cool if like that it literally
has like a cosmic origin as well in the
same way that like in in black panther
right it was something historical the
power set the heart-shaped herb the
vibranium but it's something that came
from a meteorite to earth in ancient
times right uh like all these things uh
that's one cool thing about the mcu is
that ultimately everything about it is a
is like an immigrant story it's
something arriving to earth and then
finding a new home there uh and every
character has to leave where they came
from and make home somewhere else uh and
that's the america
that not only is the american story i
think that is the human experience right
so
that's one thing i've always liked about
the ncaa i really hope that the inhumans
are already established in the mcu in
that like at the very least i would love
if lockjaw made a cameo in this show
like out because like lunch on the
teleporting dog like you i feel like
he's the most easy to love in human no
one like everyone loves dogs just put
long john the show and be like who's
this dog i don't know you could be my
dog it'd be hilarious i agree i think
lockjaw is like groot many people's
access point to that side of the world
but like roots i think lockjaw would be
a reason why we might not see inhumans
or at least not him because he's a huge
freaking dog in a huge vfx line item
budget thing like that's why we don't
see hulk and a lot of stuff because it
just costs so much to do that and it
seems like they're spending their money
on other things on this show don't have
that huge of a budget so i i don't know
if we would see lockjaw i think we'd
sooner see edson mount in the mcu in a
616 version but you know we got to point
out uh iman vilani throwing some shade
at kevin feige
saying that the mcu is not 616. i mean
that speaks to how much of a true comic
nerd she is because in her mind 616 is
the easiest way to refer to the comics
the universe and in her mind it is
always 19999
and i i think this quote was so fun to
hear her take the stance i will say nope
that's not for you to decide him on i'm
sorry i know you're i respect your
opinion but ultimately marvel studios
calls the shots here fighting we dig the
passion for sure like we love you yeah
there's so much more to talk about from
this episode we're gonna get to it all
first we want to thank some friends who
helped us make this episode brooke
lennon father's day is just around the
corner and this is the year to branch
out beyond the typical coffee mug or the
funky tie gift upgrade your gift and
game with brook linens cozy bedding
towels robes and other home essentials
brooklyn offers luxury hotel level home
essentials that don't break the bank by
working directly with suppliers brooklyn
cuts out the luxury markups and passes
those savings back to their customers so
you can get incredible products at a
reasonable cost is dear old dad still
using the same towel from 1988 give them
an upgrade with brooke linen's cozy
towels made with the highest quality 100
turkish cotton if they like a little
luxury go for the super plush towels or
keep it simple with the classic check
out brooklyn's gift guide for gifts at
every price point like now with a
father's day bundle that saves you up to
15
you can also take brooklyn and signature
softness outside the home with their
loungewear collection featuring the
coziest tees tanks sweatshirts socks and
other essential basics so give them the
comfort refresh they deserve and get it
for less at brooklyn go to brooklyn.com
and use promo code inside marvel to get
twenty dollars off your purchase of one
hundred dollars or more plus free
shipping that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n dot com and enter
promo code inside marvel for twenty
dollars off plus free shipping brook
linen the curators of comfort so so
treat that yusuf in your life he
deserves it he loves you so you need to
show him some love we wanna make helix
sleep for sponsoring this episode
whether you've got cosmic powers or not
nothing makes you feel more powerful
than a good night's sleep that's why i
am so glad to spend my nights resting
away comfortably on a helix mattress
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you sleep they have soft medium and
firm mattresses matches great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot and
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains both
mt and i have helix mattresses we both
love them so just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up or if you don't love it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix leap.com slash
inside marvel again that's helix
sleep.com inside marvel and we want to
thank upstart for sponsoring this
episode we've all been hit by an
unexpected expense or a bill in times
like that it's normal to not know where
to turn but luckily upstart is here to
help upstart powered personal loans can
help you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms upstarter has
helped over 1.8 million customers on
their path to financial freedom whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating hydrostat or funding
personal expenses upstart can help you
get one fixed monthly payment with a
clear payoff date rather than looking at
your credit score alone upstart's model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
check out your rate in minutes for loans
between one thousand fifty thousand
dollars without impacting your credit
score you can even receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com marvel that's
upstart.com marvel to check your rate
today don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we set you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information providing your loan
application go to upstart.com
marvel all right back to the episode
empty let's just talk about kamala's
powers where did kamala go when she put
on that bangle for the first time who
were those shadowy figures behind her
and what exactly is this hard light that
she can now harness yeah like her powers
are super unique and obviously very
different from the comics but like i
really dig what they're doing with it
and like the story that they're telling
with it um a lot and like when she did
go into that weird like zone i i got
hardcore um avatar the last airbender
vibes and like that made me think about
how like all these people that she's
seeing could be the past wearers of the
bangle and um could like all be like
ancestors and she went to this weird
ancestral plane
for like her from her lineage and from
her from her heritage and so um
hopefully in like we we do
i don't know like hopefully that is like
the connection that they're going for
because like in the miss marvel comics i
was actually reading this last night um
there's actually a uh inhuman villain by
the name of lineage and like his whole
deal is
going through the past of like um
different his ancestors and like getting
information so like i hope that lineage
is like the villain of this series
that'd be really fun um but like i think
that there's some type of um
like heritage and like you know
obviously her mom's mom um had a uh some
type of cosmic dealing with the bengals
so like i think that
that could be what's going on there and
maybe she's getting her powers from her
ancestors like who knows um but like i
definitely feel like um this this her
the actual power center what her actual
blue and red powers are like just
like infinity energy like i think this
whole mcu is like revolves around the
infinity stones and all these energies
and i think that her powers are dark
energy and chaos energy meshed into one
and like the chaos energy within the her
um and within this blue dark energy is
what um hardens the dark energy which
allows it to crystallize which sounds
like a bunch of gobbledygook but like
it's just like
space it's just space stone and reality
stone slash chaos magic
working together which is why it appears
purple because it's blue and red
interacting together um so that's what i
think that her powers is it's just like
the infinity energies that are already
inside of her but um who knows i'm very
much looking forward to seeing how they
explained it and like seeing if we
actually get her comics extra powers
later on because i feel like that's what
we're gonna get eventually i feel like
all of this this miss marvel like
colorful arm stuff this is all just an
origin story in my opinion for her
eventually getting her real stretchy
powers from the comics and like we just
have to slowly work our way there which
is why which is why i believe that when
kevin feige says we're just not at that
point in the mcu yet he's just like
something has to happen and in the
comics like there's the the pterogenesis
bomb that we talked about last week um
that like was the catalyst for the
actual physical change and i think that
that's what needs to happen like the a
type of terrigen mist or something needs
to interact with the human being anatomy
for all the energies to like physically
bond to their being so that they can
actually physically change like for
kamala to make a big arm like for real
and like all this stuff but like what
we're seeing now are the components of
that future change if that all means
yeah i i hear what you're saying mt i
don't kevin feige didn't say yet in his
quote though like he just said we're not
at this point in the mcu maybe there was
an implicit yet but i hear what you're
saying i i think that totally could be a
direction they go like that this is like
uh a stage this is the the metapod stage
and we're getting to the butterfree
stage but right now all metapod knows
how to do is harden right
versus metapod they just hardened all
afternoon uh but then we're waiting for
a butterfree who is truly transformed uh
and that's honestly my hope but if the
mcu doesn't go there i'm not going to
demand that they don't you know change
her powers but like i like i love her
powers the way they are they're
beautiful like i think they look very
visually appealing and like it's dope i
like i'm not complaining but i really
hope that they um that this is a origin
story but like it doesn't have to be i
mean but you do point out something that
is true in the comics the first initial
form that kamala khan takes is that of
of carol danvers right coming out of
that cocoon right and that's i can see
why they did not want that to be the
case here in the show um and then
ultimately she's just like i can just
look like myself and be stretchy as well
but like there is that you know that
structure of she has like a weird form
that she takes and then she has her
final form uh and that tends to be the
evolution of all these marvel characters
they always have like a mach 1 version
of their armor or their powers or
whatever it is and then they shed off
that outer layer and then they finally
reveal who they actually are but i'm
wondering if just like the way that
cosmic
energy overtook her just had like an
interesting fluidity to it and i wonder
if that's just going to be what they
call the terrigen mist and that this
hard light is literally
what the terrigen missed cocoon looks
like that hard light layer is going to
take a cocoon form at some point and
then break away and reveal what she
actually looks like that may be the
she's actually using pieces of the
cocoon to do all these things to him big
it and that on the other side of it
she'll actually be truly stretchy but
again if she's not really stretchy it's
okay there may be some other form that
it takes that's just like my
i'm trying to imagine if they have g
willow wilson's comics from 2014 and
they are using that to form pre-visits
and storyboards and scripts of how the
mcu live action kamala khan is going to
look
at some point why do they make that
change like and how do they adapt it to
where they're like okay well instead of
her being stretchy what if we did this
i'm sure they have like a whole bunch of
other artists who pitched a lot of
different alternate forms and eventually
they're like this looks cool why don't
we do this but they're gonna have to
have some explanation for what exactly
it is hard light is not enough and if
they never explain hard light it's gonna
be weird uh so i assume we're gonna find
out uh and i think you're right i think
the fact that it is this
purple tinted nether realm
it just feels like ancestral plane it
feels like the duat it feels like what
we've seen in the mcu before right i
think you're right i think these are
past wearers of the of this technology
if not this particular bangle of other
bangles like if you compare this to the
to the green lantern power set this
would be something like the green
lantern core other people have other
rings other bengal wearers uh and that
she's actually part of a network a
community of people who have these
powers that's my thinking
and that uh it's similar to how like you
know in captain marvel carol danvers
they have this scroll technology that
has you relive your memories uh or we
experience your memories uh the cree
supreme intelligence is also an early
fused process that shapeshifts based off
of what's in your inner desires based
off of a kind of wish fulfillment so
this extraterrestrial tech is kind of
this mind makes your reality type of
thing projecting things that are in your
heart and in your soul uh and i think
that is what this cosmic tech really is
at the end of the day i don't know how
the hell they're going to explain it in
the mcu or if they'll ever explain it
but i think we need some kind of
explanation don't you
yeah i i really hope that it links to uh
shang chi's ten rings because i feel
like there's somewhat similar things
going on there with like when we use the
rings they if they go they glowed blue
and like they seem to be
like i'm just wondering where
the power is coming from when it comes
to these artifacts like where where is
it being sourced from is it coming from
the like 10 rings or from the actual or
are these
like artifacts or the tamarinds and the
bangles sourcing their energy from like
outside or like coming coming into the
energy like i'm just wondering how the
energy flow works and how these actual
artifacts work and give them the powers
and i really hope that they get into the
science behind them um like when we
learn more about kamala's um
like family and like who else owned the
bangles before her like i i just i'm so
interested to see like what is the
science of this bagel how does it work
okay let's move on to uh an interesting
easter egg that came up the photon
gloves in the closed caption they
capitalize photon to me this sounds like
the first mention of the character of
photon the fact that she would have that
name monica rambo now we know her mother
maria rambo photon was her call sign
right so we were wondering if they she
goes by photon and spectrum in the
comics it seems like they're going to be
calling her photon in the mcu but this
just has they didn't name her that in
wanda vision i asked the directors about
this i was able to do a one-on-one
interview with them uh they kind of
ducked the answer they said that was
above their pay grade which to me says
yeah that was another line from marvel
studios from kevin feige i just want to
know how do you think kamala and bruno
even know who photon is it'd be one
thing if they could just listen to scott
lang's podcast to learn about everything
that happened in end game but monica
rambo did not really enter the chat
until juan division so how do people
know what happened in west view i get
out doctor strange knows what happens in
west view but how does the general
public
know what happened there specifically i
understand if they're like oh the
scarlet witch wanda maximoff maximov
overtook a city
uh and weird stuff happened in that city
but like everything that happened with
monica rambo was kind of confined to
her just passing through that hex wall
going to like a vacant street corner and
then being able to dodge some bullets
like who would have spilled the beans
about that like how would anyone know
what happened with monica rambo or know
that her name is photon that's very true
i mean like i wonder like where in the
marvel timeline specifically this show
happens because like
like i'm just i'm just wondering how
much photoning monica rambo has done
since wanda vision and like um if she's
just been like a superhero now on earth
and like if she's just like all right
i'm photon now for a little bit and then
i'm going to go to space to help nick
fury um so i'm just wondering like how
monica herself is going to factor into
this show because i feel like eventually
we're going to see brie larson if brie
larson doesn't appear in the show i'm
going to be very upset but like i mean
not really but like uh but i i just want
to see if monica herself is a hero like
at this point if she just like fully
embraced it and um just went full
captain marvel because she herself was
the original captain marvel fan she was
the first one um as lieutenant trouble
and um so yeah like it's hard no matter
where in the timeline it is at the
ending of one division she was still in
west view right and then uh joined a
scroll to go up to visit nick fury in
space so like
what would she have been doing on earth
like how would anyone on earth know what
she's doing i think this is like i don't
know i think this is just an example of
the show just saying like everyone just
knows everything like she's here now but
i think this is also just like an issue
that i think some people are gonna gripe
about like
the fact that uh kamala khan is such a
carol danvers fan
like we haven't carol davis is such a
relative newcomer to planet earth like
would there be this much merch about her
and posters of her even in a year after
avengers end game or two years after
avengers end game like i assume there
would be some captain marvel fans it's
just like a lot of people wouldn't
really know who she is even through
scotland's podcast you just hear you
know paul rudd talking about this cool
badass who was here in the 90s at some
point and then came back like i think
it's kind of sweet in a way that one kid
heard that story and was like yes
that sounds awesome and and built her
whole life around that it's just a
matter of timeline we have time for one
more question and this might just be me
uh reading too much into it
uh kamala's mom muniba fascinating
moment where she packs bruno a to-go bag
of food
and she does it in 10 seconds flat and
it's kind of a joke right bruno said how
did he do that that fast
is this just a joke and if it's just a
joke awesome i love the joke
but could she have speed powers could
she have oh my god
she just randomly had speed powers and
she was an inhuman on the low and she
just didn't tell her kids at all that
would be so funny i would love that so
much i mean if it's if it's just a joke
i think it's a pretty funny gag and i
hope the show does more of these gags
because otherwise this is not that kind
of show it seems like
uh her i mean oh another thing she put
those hulk costumes together pretty fast
i mean maybe she had them maybe she was
working on him for a couple weeks before
that but she put those hulk together the
whole costumes together
within like an hour it's true right or
work through the night she's a great mom
i think we can agree either way she's a
great mom i i like even though her
family dynamic is kind of like tough i
would love her family so much like i
don't want to be part of this family
like let me join yeah now yeah i think
it's a challenge absolutely to have a
mom who won't let you go to avengers con
who like
expects you to uh go
this traditional path and marrying
someone and not pursuing your own dreams
like absolutely that's a challenge but
let's not forget munima defending her
daughter to an irrational degree to that
driving instructor like was so sweet
just to see a mom when it comes to other
people who are not in the family defend
your family no matter what happened you
always defend your family and then
privately then you talk to your kid like
i think that is such a that's such a
wholesome thing to see at the beginning
of the show i love that so much i love
her mom like their whole family i really
love her dad so much like oh my let him
go to avengers con next year all right
kamala be nice to do your dad yeah
what a good dad to have like you don't
actually have to look at the mirrors
just act like you're lucky
like do not take that advice definitely
check your mirrors when you're driving
oh my god that was
and then the mom's saying no you do have
to check your mirrors are you crazy
[Laughter]
yes muneeb khan does not have to have
speed powers that's fine i'm just saying
it was pretty fast it would be hilarious
if you did i wouldn't hate it
it doesn't seem like that kind of show
that shows like marge simpson gags where
they can do superhero uh human feats but
you know we did the same thing with
hawkeye right with
with eleanor bishop flicking the
character in her mouth like she's an
acrobat
well that still could be the case we
don't know like
we still have more eleanor bishop to see
who knows
[Laughter]
well i can't wait to dive more into the
show with all of you uh mt this has been
a delight as always we'll leave it there
for this episode of inside marvel don't
forget to check out our great merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com follow
me at ea boss follow mt and
mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you so much for watching see you
next week
you